a team did win last night the washington
football team or as they say
uh in the dmv uh hail to the football
team
these days uh they are your nfc east
champs
um great story
organizationally below the owner yeah
about that that's right great story
multiple great multiple great stories uh
yeah multiple great stories for the
football team to be in the playoffs and
um here's what they've won uh a date
with tom brady there's already a little
bit of back and forth going
young chase young saying that uh he's
ready to get after
the goat bruce aryan saying be careful
what you wish for youngster
um yeah but i i guess i just wanted to
talk about tom and i don't know about
you man but i look at the
the nfc playoff field
and i say to myself after all of that
are we gonna be sitting here in about a
month
talking about brady in another super
bowl
i mean it just it feels like he's
rounding in the form i'm not ready to
pick him
i'm not ready to pick them to come out
of the nfc yet but i'm saying just
watching them these last couple of weeks
it's like here we go again here we go
again i think i got some injuries to be
to be worried
about but he's on one right now and and
by all one i mean a couple of things but
mainly a mission to have to be the first
quarterback
to have his team play host to the super
bowl
before i talk about him specifically
i just want to ask you mentioned chase
young where where'd he go to college i'm
just trying to remember
[Laughter]
oh man oh man oh get ready oh get ready
i'll go look look mike don't don't let
them win don't
win all week today all week oh all week
and if they win a week from tonight all
year because i'm gonna
change that thing around you mention it
is the pocket square is that is that a
scarlet accent with a gray blazer oh you
know you know what
that could be but this could be more
like football team this could be more
like the
this could be washington football team
kind of like a maroon more than scarlet
okay
but no i i think no in all seriousness
i'm happy i'm happy for tom brady
because i don't know if people
nationally realize
what happened the last couple of years
in new england
last couple of years like the last five
or six years in new england
tom brady has been
that they have prepared for his exit
he wanted to come back it was not his
choice it was not his choice to leave
that was not his preference his first
choice was to come back to new england
he wanted to
drew brees contract drew brees got that
two-year 50 million
deal that's all he wanted give me two 50
mil
i'm good i'm staying here i'm not
selling my overly uh price my like
overpriced
mansion in brookline massachusetts i'm
staying right here but they wouldn't
give him the contract
and so that he was forced to leave
as as a friend of ours tommy curran uh
wrote a while ago he said it was the end
of the ride
in the sense that they drove up the
patriots drove up to the driveway
and stopped and like okay
you got to get out the car like we're
here we're here you got to go
so they made him leave and the
suggestion was
that he was in a decline so for to see
him at 43 years old
not only throwing 40 touchdown passes
mike but going to a completely
this is a different offense in new
england this is the opposite
of the new england middle of the family
short passing game
we spent the entire year wondering
whether this relationship between him
and bruce arians
uh he figured it would actually be able
to work would they figure it out
you know was this you know i knew even
at the beginning of the year when the
saints beat him
in the opener i knew it would take him
some time to adjust given that like
everybody else
didn't have an off season but i didn't
know he would adjust to the tune of 40
touchdowns
like i could i could not have if i were
a betting man i would have lost that bet
if you say yo
brady's gonna throw 40 touchdowns and
she's like he's 43 years old i was like
i give him 30 but 40 of them things
and so i look at if i look at the
landscape in the nfc mike and it's like
you know my guy rogers is sitting back
minus his left tackle but he's sitting
back about to win his third mvp
he's got that by sort of you know
everything's got to come through lambo
you know the saints not sure what to
make
of them they're going to play they're
going to play the saints are going to
play the bucks in round two and green
bay is going to take on the rams we're
going to be seattle but anyway i'm not
trying to do my best your money right
now
i was trying to throw that oh but that
was a really efficient that was a really
efficient way you did that i like that
but all i was just going to say was
there's nobody
and we'll get to the afc in a moment but
there's nobody i'm just like oh they're
the clear favorites
in the conference yeah green bay is the
one seed and they got the presumed mvp
but there's nobody i think green bay is
like though oh yeah i said green bay is
that not not like kansas city though do
you look at green bean and nfc the same
way you look at kansas city in the af
no cause kansas city kansas city that's
what i mean
like no result would surprise me i don't
even want to overlook the football team
as as spunky as they are i don't want to
overlook them i mean you know crazy
things can happen but i'm saying if i
were a betting man
talking about my bedsheet money i know
i'm speaking your language right now
if you say michael you gotta place a bet
on a team to come out of the nfc
right now i probably put it on tom brady
because i just it feels like i've seen
this movie before
it's a it's a remake but i've seen this
plot and it's like he's gotten better as
the year has gone on
and he's getting more comfortable he's
having fun he out here getting his boys
their money getting getting antonio
brown to hook up and whatnot
i love that it's just it seems like this
script
it seems like the script is falling into
place for him to add another notch to
his belt again by being at home for the
super bowl
yeah i'm just like there's so many
things uh in this tom brady story i'm
going to tell you the the bad part in a
second
but the good things to see the arm
strength which is not supposed to be
one of his uh one of his best
characteristics but
he was able to throw the deep ball
especially lately throwing a deep ball
very well to see that to go to a
completely different
system and to thrive there to get a team
into the playoffs for the first time in
13 years
to change the just the expectations
of the tampa bay buccaneers but this is
what i don't like okay those are all
good things for tom brady
and it probably makes you uh want to
revisit the conversation we had a while
ago
about when uh tom brady versus lawrence
taylor when i said
brady is the best player i've ever seen
probably makes you want to think about
that a little bit more no it doesn't
because no it absolutely does it don't
answer this question
don't answer this question because i i
almost don't want to know the answer
what was lt doing when he was 43 i don't
want to know never mind
i don't want to know that i want to know
but here's the bad here's the bad part
unfortunately when the bucks beat the
football team
they're going to your hometown they're
taking on the saints and i think that's
just a bad matchup for him bad matchup
saints
have ragdolled them twice then even if
the
bucks are competitive in that game i
just don't think that's uh
a good matchup i think their their
season ends right there hey thanks for
watching brother from another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you